at first glance persona 5 scramble might
seem just like an action spin-off but
it's more than that it feels like the
sequel to persona 5 that I always wanted
it's also a really good Musso game too
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
those are pretty bold claim Michael tell
me why you think it's a sequel well it's
a continuation of the persona 5 timeline
I think it takes place six months after
the events of the original game and the
characters are older and you'll see haru
and Makoto they're in college and Joker
comes back to Tokyo and soju is coffee
shop and everyone's there to celebrate
his return but it picks up where that
game left off it's a new story there's
gonna be new characters you'll have new
places to explore and we played the demo
so we got a taste of that and yeah we
saw Sofia who's a new character there's
also a hint of another new phantom thief
who's gonna go by the codename wolf and
he's apparently supposed to be some sort
of investigator into what the Phantom
thieves are up to again okay at least
that's what it seems like but he gets
involved and he'll be in the mix as well
and there's new places to explore like
you'll be going to Kyoto you'll be going
to Osaka there's a lot more narrative
development than just an action game who
knows where the story's gonna go I don't
expect it to be as bold or as
provocative as the original game but it
seems like there's a lot of effort being
put into you know pushing persona 5
forward play persona 4 arena and it had
kind of like a visual novel presentation
what does this do to kind of stand out
more from that yeah so persona 4 arena
was the fighting game spin-off for
persona 4 and there's also been persona
queue and for some q2 which aren't
exactly Canon I guess but p5 scramble
it's not just telling a new story in
visual novel form like some of those
other spin-offs have done you are
actually walking around as if this was
persona 5 in and around towns you're
talking to people you're going to
vending machines there's so much more
side content and you spend time with the
characters in this game and the same
form you do with the original game so
it's taking a lot of the presentation
style from the core game rather than
just taking the characters and some of
the some of the stylings of p5 this is
actually using the basis the foundation
of a lot of the parts that we loved
about this 105 for this game now I don't
have that much experience with Musso
games I haven't really played any
dynasty warriors but then you play fire
emblem warriors
Warriors played a bunch of dynasty
warriors how is p5 scrambled gameplay
wise differentiating itself from all
those other looser games so the the
biggest thing about Musso games is when
they have a licence like this and they
try to find a way to set themselves
apart gameplay wise for sure and this
one does a really good job of pulling
from persona that I really enjoy there's
a lot of emphasis on doing all sorts of
acrobatic maneuvers there's a lot of
parkour jumping up on street lights and
swinging around on them to get special
attacks you can lead into all-out
attacks there's also a big emphasis on
spell casting and weaknesses for the
specific enemies yeah coming into this
and seeing how much of the source
material is put into the combat system
is also what sold me because it's
evoking a lot of the things that I like
about the combat in persona like the
weaknesses and you'll be able to switch
between different personas on the fly
and that momentum that you feel the
style the fast moving of everything that
you get from persona 5 that is
translated so well in scramble doing an
all-out attack is very simple if you hit
a weakness and then you press circle and
then everyone jumps in and it keeps it
moving this game keeps it moving
if you don't have to like action games
because you're going to remember all
those mechanics from personam like no
this is it's been translated into action
extremely well and you don't get to play
as the different characters yet in the
demo but based off of the footage you've
seen from the Japanese preview releases
is that you'll be able to play as you
scale you gene Mauch atoll they're all
gonna be in there they're gonna be
controllable on top of having the new
characters so this is it's more than
just button mashing I also appreciate
how many elements you have to work with
you also have Showtime attacks which are
a thing from persona 5 royal that's
being translated into this game okay and
it's like a midway between you know your
regular tax and your all-out attack
you'll have to show time attack just do
even more damage and then you can break
bosses armor down so ya get all out of
tax on them
Dixey
[Music]
I can see enough layers in the gameplay
systems to wear this it doesn't have to
devolve into a button mashing game
there's there's still opportunities for
protected and it pays off you get really
cool flashy cinematic stuff when you
wear all their armor down and all that
and it just feels really good now for me
I've played every persona 3 4 and 5
spin-off there has been thus far I love
the dancing games
I love the cue games on 3ds and of
course I like p4 arena playing some
fighting games you know how we do it but
there's something special about p5
scramble because of how much love and
care I can see being put into this game
thus far when it comes to continuing the
things that we loved about the
characters about the Phantom thieves
like our favorite parts of exploring
Tokyo exploring more of Japan those are
the key elements that get us attached to
these games rather than simply playing
off of our love established in the base
game it's kind of a continuation and
seeing more of these characters develop
on top of being a fun action game from
what we played so far the demo for
persona 5 scramble is out on Japanese
PSN and a shop it's also coming out
there on February 20th
but we're still awaiting onward for a
Western release date and if you want
more news and to keep up-to-date with
everything persona 5 scramble keep it
right here in GameSpot
[Music]